today's topic Adam 22 if you aren't
aware adam22 is a YouTuber also an adult
star with his wife Lena they run only
fans very very popular makes them a lot
of money and Adam's come under Fire for
being a sneaker if you will 10 days
after getting married decided to let
another man uh do it with his wife for
the first time
it's finally happening wow I did not
know you were gonna do that
little back story Adam 22 previously up
until even as early as a year ago said
he would not want to do that he wasn't
open to it now would you guys ever have
a dude be in your scenes no no
we got a one-way thing going here
one-way thing I mean we're monogamous in
our private lives and then we do [__] on
camera with other girls right I got too
much money to have her getting donkey
linebacker I can't do it should I use
that same logic on you I've got too much
money to let my man do this if you want
to cancel plug talk
but changes in find recently
and the internet has been letting them
have it including Andrew take there's a
guy called adam22 once again I have no
idea who this man is I just saw on
Twitter yesterday that he was with a
porn star who'd never done a male scene
they got married and like a week after
their marriage she did her first male
scene with some random dude and he's on
a podcast defending it that his wife had
sex with somebody else correct
why like this this is the level you
could this but this is what the Matrix
wants from you as a man they want the
woman in charge and the man below with
no backbone because if the woman's in
charge they can emotionally affect her
they can scare her that's why we have
birth rates declining porn women who are
running around sharing one man with no
intention of having children like where
do we think this is going to end I like
how adjectives talk about like oh look
at this look at this filth and
degeneracy of today's society dude has
like multiple families she's like shut
up bro you guys move away he has
multiple families he has multiple women
with multiple kids it's like you're not
any better in regards to how you a lot
of dudes are hedonistic in different
ways and they want to judge other
people's form of Hedonism like theirs is
better oh no this is more traditional
why everybody doing a lot of
grandstanding about what kind of
relationship form people should have but
if you look in their closet a lot of
them are degenerate everybody reacted
okay everybody feels some type of way
about Adam 22
and his wife a year ago though he was
saying he wouldn't let his wife do a
scene obviously you see with like the
Will Smith thing like you know the idea
that that Will Smith would allow
somebody else to [__] his wife is like
the so beyond most rap fans
comprehension so I mean I still haven't
done that again but
you know we had the conversation I
wouldn't say that I've like completely
ruled it out although I also I'm not
really like
it's not like I wanna you know I'm not
on that cuck time like I'm I'm just I'm
a bit surprised that people care this
much only because of this yes go ahead
he's an adult video star you can go on
Xvideos or any other website and you can
watch videos of handbag and other women
and begging his wife
they both do videos with other women and
other people they've been doing that so
the idea of a an adult actor engaging in
an unconventional relationship it's like
that's that's normal to me most of the
adult actors that you see in the
industry who are married a lot of them
let their wives do it with other
partners do I think it's a weird
relationship Dynamic sure but they're
already Pawn Stars it was never normal
to begin with to me now is there any EV
jealousy ever
[Music]
none of these people would have cared
about this relationship Dynamic if Adam
kept banging every other woman on this
planet but the moment She Bangs one
person everybody loses their mind so I
don't even know if this is about being
traditional
I just think this is about dudes and how
they feel they want to run their
relationship but I'm just like run it
how you want to run it let other people
run theirs the way they want but we need
to stop talking about we literally we
want traditional marriages when
[__] had nothing to say about
the fact that Adam was running three
Sims and then just banging other women
on his own all the time
I don't know I just I don't understand
what people are really complaining about
that deeply because it just doesn't make
that sense to me someone who's always
been weird is doing more weird [__]
it's like finding out sneakers still
cucks like yay okay what the thing is
maybe it's because I have friends in the
industry yeah right and they tell me
that that's the hard part of being in
the industry and that industry is having
partners right because that's important
Chelsea comes up well I have a problem
with is one of the girls like doing her
thing and everything and stuff and she's
doing that industry and that work with a
whole bunch of other guys you know when
she turns around like what Andrew Tate
is stating is let's say for example in
that industry if you have a girl that's
working as a prawn star doing her thing
banging into the dudes and the minute
she's with another guy that is in the
industry as well
she feels some type of way when he does
that with I understand where that would
apply because it's like you're you're
doing the same thing and now you're
trying to dictate what others doing the
same thing as you
have a problem remember back then we had
a video where there was a girl saying
that she was saying oh it's really hard
to be in that industry and then having a
partner and then the other question was
is there jealousy of course there is I
don't want him to do this and that now
I'm like yeah but you're out there doing
the same thing that's what I would have
a problem with but they don't they don't
have a problem with they do that so to
me it's a nothing sandwich it's nothing
do I would I prone and would I would I
promote this lifestyle or this thing no
but that's what they do I just don't
know why people care now I suspect it's
two things that are really playing in
this one a lot of people don't really
consume as adult content or know he does
adult content so for them they just seem
as a YouTuber partially or they just
haven't really accepted the fact that's
what he does and two I think a lot of it
has to do with the fact that she got
with a black guy I'm just telling you
this right now I noticed that racial
Dynamics play heavily into these kinds
of situations I suspect that she would
have just banged some regular looking
white dude right who wasn't like or some
even some Asian nobody would have really
cared but it's the idea of being
emasculated by somebody who's more
masculine than you and he's banging your
wife out that's what a lot of people are
playing to I know this because even when
I dance with Molina right even though
nothing happened everybody was writing
like BBC fan fiction and all this other
weird stuff and there was a huge racial
component that really played out of you
dancing dancing
people right like yo B yo the BBC ran
through her and entered through her push
and then came out her mouth like they
were writing like tentacle-time [__] it
was crazy
from somebody I never spent any alone
time with that's how Wild everybody went
and I think the third part about this
that's probably me and everybody feels
some top boys they just recently got
married but you have to understand the
kind of people who get married today are
not the kind of people who get married
in the past marriage today is not some
sanctimonious thing that you may feel
that way and I understand why you would
but understand a lot of people don't
engage with it that way so for me
seeing this I'm like with a generation
of 18 year olds doing only fans and
everybody and their mama being nurses
and they [__] only fans or people at
the strip club and then also doing other
jobs and all this other stuff you know
dudes trying to have harems of women
even though they're not religious any
type of way every like I'm just so used
to seeing unconventional relationships
this just looks like more of the same
I'm not saying it's a good thing I'm not
saying we should endorse it I'm just
saying I don't know why there's so much
outrage this seems pretty standard in
2023. I'm just surprised that people are
surprised yeah I'm I'm really surprised
oh word that's what makes you take
all right cool yeah like out of these
people it's it's nothing and he stated
why he's letting that happen monetarily
but people have different sets of
um priorities and they prioritize money
which is fun yeah I'm not going to tell
you how to run your physical things I
agree you haven't he hasn't said
anything about other men and that and
like if you go out there and you cheat
on your girl with a bunch of girls you
can't be mad that she does the same
thing you can't
you just you can't same thing with that
if you go out there and you you're doing
your in this industry and you do this
and that and the third if your girl does
it why are you mad oh yeah but she's a
girl man and women are different yeah
whatever yada yada that's my thoughts
anything else you want to say all right
let us know what you guys think